This group of asylum seekers is trying to climb
the fence that divides Mexico and the United States.
Among them is a 4-year-old girl,
accompanied by her mother.
Ada and her 4-year-old daughter Monserrat spent seven weeks
traveling 2,000 miles from Honduras to Tijuana
mainly on foot.
Their aim is to claim asylum in the United States.
Tijuana's government is restricting humanitarian aid
in an attempt to shut down camps like this.
Migrants like Ada and her daughter don't have access to bathrooms
or running water, and many have fallen sick.
The U.S. Department of Homeland Security also adds to their despair
by limiting the number of people who can seek asylum to a few dozen per day.
Because of this restriction,
thousands have to wait for months before they can reach U.S. soil.
Ada's decision to cross illegally
and turn herself in to Border Patrol
may seem like a way to jump the queue.
But climbing the fence in Tijuana is a dangerous choice.
Many migrants are robbed, kidnapped, hurt or even killed in the attempt.
And Ada will also risk being separated from her daughter.
The journey from Honduras to the U.S. can be dangerous for anyone,
but especially for women and children.
Ada found safety in numbers by traveling with a caravan.
After praying inside the tent, the group heads to the border.
Ada embarked on this journey because
she and her daughter were being harassed by gangs.
She is risking everything to save her daughter's life.
Their first attempt at jumping the fence is disrupted by journalists.
But this group is nowhere close to giving up.